good afternoon everyone this is Mark
Albert editorinchief of modern machine
shop magazine Welcome to our webinar
sponsored by fanic fa America thank you
for joining us our topic this afternoon
is CNC programming Made Easy with manual
guide eye conversational programming
part four Advanced turning and Milling
cycle
contouring and thread
Milling without particular knowledge of
g g gcode programming it is possible to
generate part programs on the shop floor
by answering simple questions fex guide
ey conversational programming provides
this capability for Milling turning and
Mill turn centers with fanic
cnc's part one of this series gave an
overview of the functionality of manual
guide ey Parts two and three
built on that introduction by reviewing
the entire progression of creating a
basic turning and Milling program with
manual guide eye today as part four in
this series we'll look at some of the
complex Machining tasks that this
programming system simplifies and
streamlines we'll also touch on some of
the questions asked most frequently
about manual guide eye our presenter
this afternoon is Jody
Michaels as end user account manager for
fanic fa America Jody Michaels focus is
on servicing and supporting and users to
maximize their productivity with the use
of fanic
cnc's jod has 35 years experience in the
Machine Tool industry with various
positions in sales support Automotive
applications and training at Machine
Tool Builders and users and CNC
suppliers he has a true expert on CNC
programming and the functionality setup
and use of manual guide ey
as we listen to jod during the
presentation please feel free to share
your questions with us by typing them in
the questions pane on your control panel
he will answer those questions at the
end of the presentation please keep in
mind this webinar is being recorded so
you'll be able to view the entire
program online later so thanks again for
taking time to be with us for the Live
program here's
Jody thanks Mark and as you said today
we're doing part four of our series of
manual guide eye and what we're doing
today is some of the more advanced
cycles and the first thing that we want
to cover today is thread milic this is
something relatively new and man gu ey
and to be honest it might not be if you
purchase a new machine it's typically in
the whole Machining Cycles within manual
guide eye
but a lot of machines come in from the
builders and it will not be turned on so
what you'll need to do is you have to go
into your parameters and actually turn
it on and what we're going to do at this
point is we're going to go into our MC
guide and I've got it set up right here
to where we go in and look at our Cycles
right now whole Machining usually you
have Center drilling drilling tapping
leing boring fine boring back
but you see there's
no there's no thread Milling so all we
need to do to turn that on if we get out
of this and we go down you have to be an
MDI to change a
parameter and you go to
system and it's parameter
27095 you type that in then press the
number search key and it's bit number
five
and for all some of you out there that
don't understand how fanic does
parameters you start from the right hand
side as SP zero one two three four five
and you can say on with a number one it
puts a one in there and then now when we
go back to our graph to our manual guide
eye back to
edit and we go right shift back into our
Cycles now when we arrow down now we
have a
another another cycle there and it's
threadmill so that's how you turn it on
it's probably in all the machines out
there but a lot of times like I say the
Builder won't turn it on when it first
comes into your facility so you can go
do that all right and typically the
parameters are set up to make it
work all right so at this point what
we're going to do is we're going to go
through the procedure for actually using
the thread Milling we're just going to
make a short little program we'll make a
new program and we'll say it's
4444 okay and this will be it's sort of
a review of one two and three also so
it's a good thing so we go into our
fixed
forms and we put our start lines in and
we go up and fill those out and as we
talked about on number one it's critical
that you have tool set up correctly for
whatever Cycles you're going to do and
that's one thing about thread Milling I
want to emphasize because I've got a lot
of questions from people before this
webinar about thread Milling what kind
of tool do I have to use because when
you go into your tool offs set page it
does not
show within our thread data tool data it
doesn't show a a thread Milling tool All
We Got Is drill champer flat End Mill
balln andil Tab and we have reamer
boring and face what you need to use to
make thread mailling use the tap type so
we know that tool number five is a tap
and it's a half inch in diameter so we
use tool number five so five
alter and then five alter on the
diameter then we go down zero on our
positioning in X and
Y then Z 1 in then Al for that like I
said this is a good review of what we've
done
before and then B5
again and then we'll go down to some
speed say a th000 RPM which might be
fast go with that anyway and then a feed
rate associated with that we want to
make sure we always do that it's good
practice for Manu guide ey and g54 and
alter that and now at this point we go
back into our cycle
For Thread
milling and we go down to thread
Milling okay we select
that and again it's just like all the
cycles that we've went over before just
fill in the blanks and wherever it's
highlighted that's what it wants right
now it's saying the thread diameter it's
wanting the major diameter of the thread
we're going to M so we're going to say
this is an inch and a half
diameter okay 1.5 in there or right or
leftand thread we're going to say a
right hand thread it can either be
metric or unified so it's either metric
or inch we're going to say it's an inch
thre I think most of us thinking answer
but
whatever then we get a tech conditions
you got three different types of threads
here within thread note and this is
great because it more or less covers all
the different types of tooling that you
might use one is just one revolution
that would be a threadmill has
multiple
uh it would look like a tap multiple
fluts then the second one is thread
Revolution and what that is it's got a
single point type to and then number
three is that's a type that where
there's an insert on it it's got
multiple tips on it we got three
different choices so we'll go with the
first number one first and then the r
plane then cut depth and see on this
either plus or minus we'll say minus 2
in a clearance plane of 100,000 a feed
rate and then our approach move and then
this is just the direction of the cut a
down cut then it go past now I always
put 100 th000 in here then we insert
that and then what it'll do is come and
say okay where's our points that we want
to do so we'll say XY random points go
on the Machining Center
zero and then Zer zero and X and Y
insert that and then we'll put an end of
program okay so we won't get an alarm
when we simulate it and then at this
point I'm I'm thinking to myself now I
didn't Define a blank all we're on to do
so I go back up here and Define a blank
we go start this just show you how easy
this is it is and we're going to say
this is a hollow cylinder blank
we select that and it's five in in
diameter it defaults back to what I had
in there the last time the in diameter
is this two inch long insert that that
should be all the information we need to
actually do a thread so we go
simulate and Press
Start see it B in did the hole and the
reason I did a round part is we can cut
part of it away with cut display
then we can go rotate it to where the
cutout is on the other side
so we want go
here see now the cutouts where we can
see it and that's what's good about
rotation you can get the blank to look
however you want to CL and we Press
Start we see the tool go all the way
through and make one rotation and then
come back out so that's type one thread
Milling now what's great about the
simulation at this point we can go right
back and go down to our
cycle and press enter and it takes us
right back into it we go back into the
cut condition and now we'll do this one
type
two okay then alter then we can go in
and see in the simulation what it does
rewind then press start and see how does
it makes one reol revolution for every
pitch of the thread so that's what type
two
is then we go to group off and now we're
gonna go back into the same cycle and
then just go through number three okay
press
enter going add it of
course then we'll go and make it the
multi through that and again what it
does within the
simulation it will actually
show and see it breaks to two inches
based on having five tips to that insert
it'll know how many revolutions it makes
it needs to make to do that so it's a
very powerful cycle it's pretty much
covers all the different types of
tooling that you might get for doing
thread
milling and so it's a very powerful Cy
very good very good the Bic worked for a
good while trying to develop this and
they they done the engineers in Japan
did a great job so it pretty much covers
all the different types of tooling let
you start in the bottom and come out or
let you started to top the end so it's
very powerful very powerful so that
that's one of the first Advanced Cycles
we wanted to go over so now the the next
one that we want to go over within our
PowerPoint presentation is we we've done
the thread Milling again within the
PowerPoint it does tell you all the
parameters you need to
change then one we didn't go over when
we went back to MC guide is there for
type three you have an overlap parameter
what that does is when you use the type
of tool that has an insert on it you
want it when it makes the the individual
like a takes three passes you want those
passes to overlap a little bit and that
27451 is that
overlap so it's important that you set
that
too okay then just fill in all the data
like we
did so now the next thing we want to go
over is thread repair this is another
very powerful cycle that we have on a la
and what this enables you to do is go in
and pick up an existing thread on a part
you go back and either make the thread
longer repair deformities within that
thread face The end off and do whatever
you want to do so it's very powerful but
now it's not e I can't really simulate
this within my MC guide because it's
looking for spindle feedback things like
that so we're just going to go through
the PowerPoint presentation slides to
show you how it
works and the procedure on how it how it
works is first I'll be ly you go into
MDI make a Threading tool active
whatever tool number that might be and
you set your workof set at the front of
the
part okay once you do that you go into
jog hand wheel
remotes what however your machine
describes gone into a manual mode where
you can move it with a hand wheel or
with a jaw
but once you get into that you press
right shift key know what that is talk
about that and it will you press that
one it'll get you to this screen where
it has a repair
soft so you press the repair soft key
and that will take you to this screen
and this is just our standard
thread definition page where you can
either do outer or iner and you have
typically five different types and I'll
explain to you why you use the different
types the General type that's for if
you're going to have a tapered tread
that is non-typical if you got a a
bastard angle on the thread you want to
use General metric obviously that's for
a metric thread unified is for a
standard 60 degree
thread thread pipe thread OD that's for
a 3/4 taper per foot tapered type thread
but only for that taper you can't can't
change that taper then thread internal
type thread and that's first standard so
you select one of those then as soon as
you do that it takes you into this
screen and as you can see you've got six
tabs that you have to fill out different
information in order to do thread
repair the first one is
Orient and the important thing you have
to remember about thread repair it's a
great feature however just turning on
the option within the machine to make it
work is not enough the Builder of your
machine that you have they have to do
ladder
development to make sure that it will
work with the option they have to
develop their ladder to make sure all
the right buttons work and the reason we
don't do it with our standard ladder is
because all the machines are different
out there they have different spindle
Motors the the way it picks up the
spindle or could be different from thech
to machine so it's important that you
talk to your Builder and make sure he
developed the ladder to make this work
so it's a like I said it's a very
powerful feature but anyway at this
point what you do is you press the
Orient soft
key and once you do
that here's where it gets interesting
because this gets into where what you do
you take the hand wheel and you move
your threading tool over to where the
thread is actually on the
part and you bring it down to where the
the point of the threading insert is
right in the middle of the of the thread
itself and again this when you do this
as good as whatever your eyes are so you
want to make sure that you're very
careful here and you Center it up
closely as possible I always take a
business card and hold up
underneath the thread itself so it'll
have a white contrast for when you're
line lining up the tool in the middle of
that thread so you can see it better
that's an old trick that's an old engine
operator's trick but then once you do
that you get it directly in the middle
you press the measure soft key and it'll
put a value into this field called sync
position okay and that's what it's doing
it's lining up the Z axis with the cais
of the the spindle itself
and once you do that then you go to the
next tab where you fill in all your just
cut conditions and you've done this
before then you go into your detail data
where you do the RPM the direction of
the spindle or clearance
moves then the position this is just the
thread diameter the front of the part
the number of threads per inch the
length as you can tell on the link in
the page it's not plus or minus just an
incremental
value and then also it asks for the
thread depth as you can see it's got a
soft key down here that says
calculate so it will actually calculate
the depth of your
thread if you wanted to or if you know
the depth of the thread based on your
print you can put it in manually and
then once you do that it goes to this
other
screen the first thing you want to do
after you've done that is move the tool
out of the
thread because it'll make you do that
then you PR you press OT off and what
that does is cancels the Orient and then
you press
Start okay and then it'll go back in and
redo the
threat okay very simple just those six
paths and then you're done it'll go back
and do the entire thread cycle then just
wait until if you want to go back
thread so it's a very good feature but
but again I want to emphasize that your
Builder has to do some latter
development to make this work all right
but it's a very good feature very
powerful very powerful all right after
this the next thing we want to go over
is
engraving this is something a lot of
people ask about and again what we're
going to do we're going to go into our
NC guide to go over this and we're
actually going to again make a small
program to do engraving
right so we'll go into
edit new
program
create now when you do engraving
again you have to know what type of tool
you're going to use because engraving
it's either got to be a A balln inil or
a drill those are your two choices for
Tool selection so we'll go to our tool
offset Page look at that
and we'll go to our to data and we got
in number four we got a drill a very
small drill which that's what you want
to use when you're doing
engraving want to use something very
small and I usually use like a a very
small center drill okay because it's
very tough it's made from high speed
steel so it's going to be a little bit
more forgiving it won't break off as
easily as a solid carbine so we won't
use tool number four but again it's got
to be either a drill or a ball nose in
we're going to use four four
alter then we'll position at
zero
zero one inch again sorry I know this a
little redundant
but it's good
review and then obviously with a tool
like this you going run as fast as the
machine would go we say 8,000 RPM going
be a very small
tool and then we'll go over to the feed
rate we'll say 10 in a
minute and
g54 alter and then we want to do a a
start again and do our
blank and we'll select a rectangular
blank and still got figures where did
before okay so now we go do a
cycle okay and we're going to go we got
whole Machining we got face Machining we
got contouring pocketing grooving and
under special it's
engraving
that and again fill in the blank all the
rest clearance a feed rate then an an X
plan
the position asking for our start point
so we're going to say minus 2 and X the
first one's X the next one's in y we'll
say 2
in the base position the top of the part
we're say Z and it asks for How deep the
characters are going to be and see and
it doesn't show plus or
minus it's just an incremental value so
we're GNA say 10,000 you don't want to
put a very big value there
a little you don't want it very deep a
little break character size we're going
to say half
inch and the angle just the way it's
going to orient that we'll say
zero okay and then it asks what do you
all to do now another thing to emphasize
here there's only one font you can't
change this to cursive or some fancy
font you're stuck with whatever it
is
so put my name go
MP okay and it shows you what it's going
to
do insert
it
okay there and then so with this one
line of code here it'll do that
Engraving WR that out let me go
in go into
program so now we'll
go
Auto
ulation and Press
Start see it showed it the reason it
showed it like that is because I knew it
was going to do that but what we want to
do we want to go change the rotation of
our
block now if we go to the middle ISO
isometric view do it
again Press
Start you now put it up there and so and
you know we can go blow that up if you
wanted
to see it
better go
larger then we do it
so see then you can what's good about
simulation like we discussed before is
that you've got the capability of
fine-tuning the placement of it just
based on the
simulation and then you can just go on
from there okay so again it's very
simple to use the engraving but now one
thing you might ask is say you wanted to
do part numbers it won't let you
serialize it so to be honest I've been
trying to figure out some way where I
could increment the numb if you're doing
a part number but I frankly I haven't
figured it out yet if there's a way but
I will figure it out if there's a way
right so that's engraving but again it's
very simple the the main thing you got
to remember is get the right tool
type either a drill or a ballnose inot
that's the biggest mistake people make
is that they don't do that all right so
what we're going to do now we're going
to go back to our
PowerPoint we've done our engraving
again there slides for everything you
have to do there
also and then from there what we want to
talk about is and I'm not going to do
anything with it with MC guide about
this but I have got a lot of questions
during our webinars since the first
where a lot of people have machines out
in the field and they're wanting to add
manual
eye and but they don't have the large
screen they got the small 8.4 in screen
they want to know if it's possible to
add manual guide eye to those machines
yes it is possible and within the last
few weeks actually I've done a couple
where I've had to go in there are
certain parameters you got to change to
make it work because with the big screen
you got 10 keys underneath and the small
one you only got seven
so your two right shifts and then five
in between so you do there are some
parameters there's three pages of
parameters here that you need to change
to make those work okay I just want to
get those in there I'm not going to go
through every one of them because I
don't want to go through and change your
parameters but they're in within this
presentation where you can see them and
again I just want to make sure that
you're aware that if you have a machine
out there that's got small screen you
can add the manual guide eye the
advanced version manual guide ey to your
machine and
make
okay there's three pages for that now
next what I want to talk about is some
things that typically if I do training
if I talk to
people you know that call me about Manu
gu ey there are some parameters that
make things much easier to do
and because I get phone calls all the
time and people say well when you were
doing your webinar you had something on
your screen it's not on
mine so there's like seven of them here
that that I want to go over to make sure
that you understand that if you go turn
these on it'll make things much easier
for for you when you do your programming
on man night on now the first one that I
said I want to go over is
uh thread data access and what that does
for you is say you're an edit and you're
in a
program and this probably won't work on
your machine but when you highlight a
line where there's a tool number and a
diameter number see how this it shows a
drill it shows what that tool actually
is so say you have a program that even
if it's something that you wrote offline
if you just find the line with the tool
data in it and you go down and press
input it automatically takes you into
your tool offset table on your tool data
screen on that number tool so you know
exactly what that tool is geometry of it
and you don't have to because you know
usually what you do you go a right shift
three or four times you finally got to
your tool offet but you know that's okay
but this is much easier you just H whole
line
press input and it goes directly to that
screen okay so it makes it much
easier right and also we talked about
earlier
was the within our cycles and the whole
Machining was the thread Milling you a
lot of times you'll get a machine and it
won't have the treadmilling feature
turned off again that's a grand number
27095 you go into
system for an
MDI
70955 turn that to one and now I'll B
treadmilling up also
27451 number
search that's the overlap for when
you're doing tread millon and type three
you want to put a number in there the
number of teeth that's on your threading
insert how much it'll overlap you tell
it one it'll overlap one
too okay that's important that you said
that
also another one that you need to turn
on is
27,000 bit7 that's for
embossing and what that does is within
manual guide ey usually
when you do
a one enter go back to our gra I'll show
you where this is we go into
edit our
cycle see now up here has old machine
face machine cont trink embossing okay
what embossing is and I know all of you
have noticed this like if you're doing a
comter mill where it's going around and
Milling a circle out of a square a lot
of times it'll do a lot of passes that
are air passes where it's not taking any
material because it's going all the way
around with embossing you go in and
Define the actual outline of the rough
part then it'll only remove material
where there is material so it'll make
the the program much more
efficient much more
efficient
okay the and then another one that you
want to look at
also if we get events is
3401 number
search and what this is it's six and
seven where it has GSC and
GSB so the Sanic control there's three
different programming languages there's
a b and c usually these are only panged
on the
LA but it's it's important that you know
these for different builders
use different languages I don't know how
they decide but
they the easiest way on the L to to
determine which one it is you can look
here if they're both zeros it's program
language a if it's one in it's seven
it's program language C if it's the one
and number six it's B but on the way the
way I always tell it's based on if you
use a a G50 to limit your RPM for
constant surface speed that's program
language a it's the
g92 that's for program language
D but it's a very very nice option to
have
okay now at this point what I want to do
is get back down to this so we want to
go back to our PowerPoint
presentation we sort of went over all
those and again this CHS the different
screens how they look when you turn
things on all right rust without INF
facing rust within facing without
residual with residual the embossing tab
program langage a& the
differences all right so at that point
I'm sort of going through all those F
tuning parameters that I do and now I
want to sort of go over some 10 of the
frequently asked I get all the time
whether it's through emails or phone
calls or whatever and going through this
what I want to do again I want to go
back into and see so I can sort of show
you the
answers okay and we'll go
here go back to
graph and the the most frequently Asked
question I get all the time is
because different Builders can make
access to this is know usually when you
start up a control you'd be in this
screen this is the standard fanic G-Code
screen to get access manual guide eye
usually the builders will either use
graph function key or the custom one or
custom two or sometimes it'll actually
even be
a a heart key over here with your single
block block skip that would say MGI
I'd say probably 90% of the time either
going to be graph custom one
cust so that's a frequently Asked
question so online press gra to get into
it okay question number two is how do
you change the blank size I've people
ask me this all the time and to do that
you go into your
start you have a tab up here that says
blank you over to that and that's where
you
determine what your blank size is you
select one of these blanks fill
in the field just press insert and it's
it's it in your program but what it
always does it if you don't determine a
blank up front it will default back to
whatever the last one that was drawn so
you want to make sure you do that within
that okay another frequently Asked
question how do I get my fix forms into
my machine to do that you got to be an
edit and usually you would come up into
this
screen you go right shift four times two
three
four then press
settings register fix form sentence for
m select that and then this takes you
into where you can make new ones all
them delete them or input or output what
I'm going to do I'm going to delete
these so don't ever press that standard
button what it says is are you sure
current is overrided by standard yes see
what it does it deletes them
all so be careful before you ever do
that but then to input them PR input and
on my memory card I have a file called
form. dap press input and again it comes
up says are you
sure so you got to press the button
twice in order to do that yes
input now they're back that's how you UT
them now the next question that goes
right on with that how do I change one
to do that all you do is just airrow
down to one one of
change
alter and then you can just you know
Arrow up and down between them and then
just go and change whatever you want and
press
off all right that's how you both input
your fix forms then change them okay
another question I get all the time is
I'm trying to simulate a program but it
doesn't show a tool reason that is
number one you have to put a dword in a
program for it to pick
up whatever data you have in your tool
table it's geometry of the size of the
tool and you have to describe the tool
also whether it's a flat end mail and
the orientation of the tool also you got
to have all this data set up you have to
use a DW in order for it to show
it
okay then along with that also is how do
you make a new
tool okay to all set you just go into
one where we don't have any data you put
a value is the size of your cutter we'll
say it's 3/4 so half
that and then we'll go over here and
make it a a
tab it's as easy as that making a new
tool how you create a tool in the tool
data table and Manu that
on all right now we created a tool and
people are asking me all the time that
the tool offsets that we create in
manual guide are they used on the gcode
side yes they are they're used on both
sides so the data that you
put here you your geometry your tool
length your cerom it does pick all
that then also people are asking all the
time about whether it will simulate a
G-Code program yes it will you can
import a program from a cam system and
simulate it on menu.
do all right then also people are asking
about an undo
button doesn't have an undo button and
right on the screen you got to be an
edit obviously so like if I accidentally
deleted this line soon as I deleted
something the undo button comes up I w't
just put it back and just press undo
right back for a
l
okay the last question I have and this
one is it's number 10 on my list but I
get asked it all the time does does
manual guide eye have a material
table within manual guide I know it does
not have a standard material table but
within your fixed forms you could set
something up to where with specific
materials you can cut up spindle speeds
and feed rates and everything with a
fixed form but it does not have a
material table where once you do a cycle
or a program where it goes up and fcks
out cut speeds and feed rates based on
different types of material or tooling
data or anything like that there's
nothing like that within manual by
ey okay so at this point that's all the
the last of my 10 frequently asked
questions and you know time tuning the
parameters so at this point I'm GNA
throw that to Mark maybe we can cover
any questions that we might have from
people out there in the
audience okay I'm ready to go here Jody
thank you that that was very interesting
as as all of these uh parts of the
webinar series have been so thank you
for an informative presentation yeah
let's go to some questions from our our
audience here um I'm going to combine
two of these because they both have to
do what you're able to do with manual
guide eye uh on a uh lathe with live
tooling and the cais and one of them is
are you able to threadmill on on that
kind of
machine yes there is an option for a
live toola just like on the
mail that that you can do thread
mailling on the OD also yes as long as
you've got the right Axis you know a
live tool
machine okay yes it is it is possible it
is
possible so H how about engraving on
that same kind of uh machine yes the
engraving is totally possible both on
you know it Mark obviously if you have a
live tool a there's different
configurations of live tool lays you can
have one where there's three axes where
you have Tex Z and then the C axis on
the spindle where you're going to be
doing polar coordinate coordinate
programming so yes you can do engraving
that way and then you can have a you
know a a midd turn machine where got a y
axis then it's going to be more like a
mill lathe so you can do it both ways
but yes you can do engraving also yeah
okay um here's a couple more questions
about uh engraving um uh I believe you
did say that you can't change the font
for Engraving
correct no no there's only there's only
one
font only one font okay um is that
likely that change your future do you
think there's some plans to make it
possible to change the
farm uh I'm not sure how you would go I
guess it's possible but you know I'm not
really frankly that's probably a little
bit above my pay grade I'm not really
privileged to I've never heard that
they're gonna change
that okay that's that's I guess it could
be I guess it could be possible but I
haven't heard anything to to
substantiate that
okay um now here here's a question that
you can probably add to your list of
frequently asked questions um I know
manual guide ey is available on the
control of the machine does fanic offer
this for the desktop
version yes yes and you're right that
should be one of my 10 10 modes I mean
we do offer a couple different options I
mean you have NC guide where there's
three different versions of that Mark
you have the academic version to where
it's more it's great for students to
where you can study and practice at
night practice programming but it's
limited about the input and output
capabilities and then you got NC guide
to where it's fully you can program take
the programs out put them in a machine
and run them and then you got in guide
Pro where it could actually take the
ladder and the
parameters out of an existing machine
and put it into that to where you can
simulate the machine you have in your
shop on your desktop
totally okay so you got those three
versions and then we also got one where
it's manual guide manual guide eye only
off there still a version of that so
there are four versions that are you
know to you know several different
prices obviously so yes it's totally
possible to have something on your
desktop that you can program using the
same type of software like what I'm
using here for the demonstrations for
these
webinars what what I'm using is NC guide
the middle version of NC
guide okay all right um another question
here how do you create a contour in the
XY
plane okay that's that's very simple and
that's why I sort of left this set up is
within when you would go do a cycle you
know a contour
cycle here you know whether it be an
outside or an inside or something like
that once you fill out all those cut
parameters Mark then you go it will
prompts you into this figure a contour
figure and within those you can do a
square a circle a track or a free convex
figure you know if it's something that
you know exactly what the sizes are like
a square or Circle those are easy but if
you want to draw something you go into
X3
convex and it's just a matter of drawing
it out you know it says okay it's convex
where's my start point in X and Y zero
and
zero zero and it's minus one
in I'm not gonna go all the way through
it but see then it brings up all these
lines and then you just go through and
draw the lines the arcs corner radiuses
corner champers as long as you got a
good print you can go pretty much Define
whatever the part might be and it'll do
figering for you you know if you don't
know all the exact points it'll trig it
out for you and it will even you know
I've had it used for by people where
it'll find mistakes on the drawing or if
they've got a drawing that it says that
it's connected man you guide eye I mean
it's just like sort of like having a
mini can
system so but that's how you do it then
once you get done you press create
it creates a geometry and then you go on
from there and you machine
it okay um another question here um is
there a fixed form for chering on a
multitasking machine with you know y w y
and C
axis I I'm not sure I'm not sure I get
the question but uh maybe you take a
stab at that uh yes I think there would
actually I mean you do have within the
different Cycles you do
have you know you got outer wall
contouring and you know based
on it is possible to do that okay um
another
Cas go ahead oh I was going to say is
this something you need to check with
this the Machine Tool uh Builder to
start out so you have that capab you
know to make sure you have that
capability right right right because you
know it all have to be configured
correctly you know when the machine
would come in that you have all the
different different axes configured
correctly with a manide ey because there
are a lot of parameters because usually
it's they manual guide eye will come in
configured on a base machine you know
and a lot of times if you're getting
into multitasking type machines that are
really truly five Act of stuff you know
it'll do four you can't do five within
man
ey but the four for what you're talking
about there that that would be enough to
do to camper like what you're talking
about there you gotta go it's got to go
until a configuration standard yes it
could do that yes yes we just have to
set it up
correctly okay um I just want to remind
our audience um
okay just remind our audience that um we
still have some time left so if uh uh
anyone wants to enter some questions in
the uh question pane we'll go ahead and
we'll get to those um we'll answer all
the questions even if we don't get to
them while we're on the air remember the
webinar is being recorded and it'll be
available online so if we can't stay for
the whole session you can catch up later
so let's get back to our questions here
and this one says um can you quotes
project a pocket shape on the OD of a
cylinder to be illed
out on a cylinder
yes yes you can do
that okay um anything we know about that
or uh any tricks tips on that no no no I
mean it's a
fair I mean it's just using uh
cylindrical interpolation to do
that it's more than possible to do that
both on a lathe and on a machining
Center okay as straightforward as the uh
yeah yes it's very straightforward very
straight okay all right um let's get to
this question um will manual guide eye
offset for the diameter of a tool during
Milling yes it will
although and that this is another one of
those questions mark where I get asked
this all the time and and the reason is
is because it's a little different with
manual guide
eye than it is say with a cam system but
with a cam system it'll generate a g41
or g42
for where it offsets the tool based on
whatever the diet of the tool with a
manual guide ey you always
when you call up your tool in your tool
data it tells you the DI or the tool so
it looks at that when it makes all your
XY moves so as long as you would leave
it in the conversational mode program if
you went and change the size of your
tool it'll regenerate the code based on
whatever that size at if you convert it
to a G-Code program it does not spit out
of G 41 and 42 and it's only using
whatever the size was when you did the
original program so if you want to be
able to to change the size of your tool
you want to leave it in the
conversational
format okay okay important people know
that it's important that they know that
all right um want to get a couple more
questions in here can the set point in
the thread repair be used in a program
all work will you measure that
point yes you could yes yeah I think I
know what they're asking
yes go ahead well interpret that
question for us Jody so so the answer
makes a little more is more valuable to
us well I think what people are wanting
to find out
is and it's a great question because
with bread repair you know you're doing
doing this within a cycle that's in Manu
gu eye but you're actually orienting the
machine you're orienting the c-axis of
the spindle with your linear axis your
z-axis and that doesn't matter whether
you're on the G-Code side or the
conversational side so if you would do
that at the
beginning go in and Orient that and
measure that distance and then go run a
G-Code program it would still Pi up the
threat it would still take up the threat
and I I think that's what they were
asking so okay what what a lot of people
want to do Mark is they don't
necessarily want to use the threading
cycle within Manny V eye they want to
use their
g76 threading cycle that they use all
the time and it will work for that it
will work for that okay
okay all right uh looks like we have
time for a couple more questions would
you use the same process to put in a
keyway in a shaft and I think that same
process might be one we discussed in a
previous
question um yeah would that be
like yeah
okay all
right then um how about can you set your
work shift in manual guide
eye yes yes yes you can there's a
and and what's good about it is it still
does exactly the same thing as what you
would do on the gcod side it's just a
little bit prettier pictures so and I'm
showing it right now where you you're
going into your work coordinates and say
you want to set your X you just press
enter you want to measure and it brings
up a another calculate Offset you tell
it what that your target is like if you
want this to be zero and put that in
there and then input of course it's not
gonna change because I I haven't moved
my machine but yes you can do that like
I said the pictures are just a little
prettier than what's on the standard
side but it still picking both on both
the conversational and the GT side all
right how about using uh my renesha
probing Cycles while I'm in manual guide
eye yes yes what's good about that is
you know sort of what we talked about on
part one about where you can set it up
however you want it you know not
necessarily how I want you to set it up
just the way you want to within your fix
forms what you can do and I've had
several people do those they actually
download their
renaa uh probing Cycles so they're
usually relatively short and they put
them in their fix form and then you know
when they're doing their programming
they'll just go grab one and insert it
right into the the conversational
programming and and use it right within
manual guide
eye okay okay it is capable of doing
that all right um is it possible to slow
down my feed rate in specific spots in
turning yes yes both in
um milling and turning actually you can
do that and it's where you know we're
describing how you drill a figure if we
go in and do a continuous figure a prec
convex we go into that when you withraw
something just be something Z
zus then say okay and say we do a line
here going somewhere left enough
and say okay whenever you do that alter
it'll bring up an
attribute on the element where you can
slow down the feed rate on each
individual attribute so you could slow
down a feed rate all the way around the
outside of something just pick out where
You' want the the slower feed rate to be
so it's very easy to do that just called
the attribute I'm not sure why they
called it that but that's what
yeah okay um hey Jord I'm going to try
to squeeze in one more question here
from our audience um would you use the
same process when using a drap or a
dreamer and a drapp or dreamer that's
the combination drill um tap and a drill
reamer those are you know uh types of
cutting tools
right yeah well
that that's a good question
that's what I've never thought about
before because you have to have it tied
to the right speed rate in order for the
tap to work cck
like
so I don't know I'm G have to get back
to them on that I don't know okay I
don't want to say anything I'm not sure
about I'm not sure about well okay that
that that's certainly fair enough uh
Jody and then um to wrap this up this
last question can I just type something
something in manual in manually in
G-Code and
simulated yes with me okay yes that's
one of the good things about Manu guide
eye you know there's a lot of guys out
there that maybe the Cycles within
manual guide eye does doesn't totally
fulfill what they want to do they want
to do just something simple where they
just want to come over and make an X
move or a y move or whatever move and
you know they I've had people call me
and say well can I just type in yes just
go you know call the tool up type in
what you want to do as long as you got
your tool data correct which you know
good beat don't everybody over the head
about that get your tool data right you
can type in whatever you want and it'll
simulate it whatever you type in and
it's a great feature because you know
you can do that or use a
cycle it's a very good
feature okay
um Jody I guess we're about out of time
here so um I just want to thank you
again for presenting the slides and
answering all these good questions um
for those uh attending this afternoon
session you can contct fanic fa America
if you'd like more information I think
we can get that uh contact screen up
here in a
second
um yeah in the meantime I just want to
remind everyone if you've missed any of
the previously broadcast Parts in the
series you can find all of them on our
website MMF online under the webinars
tab and uh you can just pick the ones
you want to catch up on so I really
appreciate the time that everyone the
audience has taken with us this
afternoon and I hope you found it
worthwhile thanks for taking part um
this has been a real fun series of
webinars to be a part of so I want to
thank Jody in particular and and thank
all those who've arranged this session
and helped It Go real smoothly so this
concludes our webinar this afternoon
please have a great day everybody this
is Mark Albert at modern machine shop
magazine signing off